- As every third think
piece will tell you,
we are a fractured country.
And when it comes to guns, the
debate is as heated as ever.
Thankfully on June
11th on Comedy Central,
I, Jordan Klepper, solve guns
through an ingenious
strategy of rubbing elbows,
imbedding with the
militia, driving race cars,
and shooting big ass weapons
til a bit of sanity
returns to our country.
(gunshot)
- Miss!
- You don't have to
keep saying miss.
Just a little over a week ago,
our nation's gun divide was
on full display in Atlanta,
where the NRA held it's
national convention.
A perfect place for
me to selflessly
reach across the partisan line
and get NRA members pumped
to watch my special.
Who doesn't like common sense
approaches to gun violence?
You're for closing the
gun show loophole, right?
You're a smart guy.
So what is it that brings
80,000 gunners to Atlanta?
- It's just fun to
look at all the stuff
and see the people that
you've seen in magazines
and, y'know, on television.
- This is like Comic
Con, but for death.
- Guess I'll just have
to take your word for it.
- Bingo!
What are the fanboys
excited about this year?
- Kinda cool to walk around
and see all the new products
that come out and the new
ammo and stuff like that.
- So 2017's going to be
a good year for guns.
- Oh yeah.
- What was your favorite
shooting of 2016?
- 2016, honestly, um,
watching like Shane Coley
and those guys.
- Was he Denver?
- No, it was out
in Utah, actually,
They had a big Utah--
- Was it a mall or?
- No, what do you mean?
- Where was the shooting?
- It wasn't a
shooting like that--
- A school?
- No, it was like a
tournament, y'know.
- Oh!
I'm doing a special
where I claim to solve guns.
- Solve guns?
- I'm solving guns.
- What's solving guns
have to do with it?
- Well, you're gonna
have to watch it.
- That's the day, June 11th?
- June 11th.
- On Comedy Central?
- On Comedy Central.
- I just hope it's not comedy.
- That's me.
Guns don't solve problems,
Jordan Klepper solves problems
about guns on June 11th.
- What?
- I'm not getting through.
It's time to become a
sheep in wolf's clothing
and give these people
what they want:
Guns and witty t-shirts.
(pop)
- Who likes moderate
gun stance, huh?
June 11th!
Big tees are comin' out
of a gun, am I right?
Ho!
Oo, yeah!
Lovin' it!
Unfortunately common sense
isn't one size fits all.
If t-shirts weren't
going to solve it,
I would to have to solve it.
On Sunday, June 11th.